thank you
[Music]
welcome to uh the latest installment of
Ash Wednesday yeah Cruiser we have the
cigar fan on right okay otherwise we're
all going to die uh but you know what we
will be prepared for death because our
guest here today is new book if you see
it right there I think it just released
yesterday uh the warrior poet way
um You probably just know him as the
warrior poet yes which is two two that
means two names but really I guess we
could just call him the warrior I guess
that's taken by the Ultimate Warrior Mr
poet but uh he has the website
um uh Warrior poetsupplyco.com you know
we'll put all the links there but I just
wanted to talk with him Mr uh Mr poet
but I'll just go with do you prefer John
Lovell John Warrior John poet normally I
go by John but you said the warrior poet
with just such emphasis I really like
that I'd like a harder V and maybe a
pause like the Ultimate Warrior poet
where nightmares are the best part of my
day
um John's good man
John thanks for being here brother
thanks for having me man and uh
hopefully like that cigar um not a
sponsor but you can go grab these at
cigars daily that's the uh Bella sartes
um and we were just talking about this
so look for people who don't know uh
tell folks what is a warrior poet tell
them what you're about I ran into you I
saw some of your videos a long time ago
with my friend Mark ripito where of
course he was making fun of his he does
with everyone giving you a tough time
and he's done so with me uh and then saw
some of your videos discussing uh guns
and then podcasts and regarding faith
and it kind of all came together but
explain for people who may not know sure
uh pretty simple as somebody who lives
for higher purpose and they're ready to
sacrifice in the defense of others so
that's the big kind of banner they're
lovers and Defenders Of Truth and you
can take uh you can take the Warrior
part a little bit metaphorically if you
wanted to but I do think there should be
some physical element as well of no
we're Protectors of uh people so that's
kind of the banner and all kinds of
Creeds can Crush in under that and you
focus a lot on on sort of masculinity
and we'll get to that can can a woman be
a warrior poet yes you just can't be a
man okay
well that's gonna rub some people the
wrong way yes I know they need to be
rubbed that way yes exactly well I'm
just getting mad all the time by all the
things you can't say I'm like
I'm gonna say whatever I want though so
I don't think I'm mischaracterizing you
obviously Christian I mean you've been
worked at you've been a missionary right
um and I don't think I'm
mischaracterizing and saying well
conservative more right-leaning uh is
that okay yeah absolutely okay I don't
know because sometimes we're like well I
don't want labels um and Firearms all
this you know you've talked about sort
of being being I don't want to say
combat ready conflict ready right and
I'm sure right away sort of dealing with
this cutting it off at the past you'll
have some people say well how can he be
a Christian and leading young men as
young Christians and and be all pro-gun
and the tattoos that you got
right and so I think it's just that way
I think what they have built in their
head is a caricature of Christianity uh
but not the not the real uh the real
piece if you lean into the Bible you
realize man the heart of God is one of a
warrior he's a protector of the innocent
and real love protects right now
sometimes you're to turn the other cheek
like somebody says like I don't like
your face you know and there's one of
those interchanges not somebody most
buddy with me half of the internet
really hates your face Stephen the other
half that's fair I don't even look in
the mirror I just I hate half my face
when I look in the mirror it's like the
Face-Off cover I just do the one side
right yeah uh so real love protects it'd
be an evil terrible thing somebody
breaks in your house and they want to
hurt your loved ones and you could do
something about it but you're like no go
nuts right Jesus is okay with this I'm
like no there's a time to heal and a
time to kill you know and so there is a
time for both actions and so he's built
some people to be physical protectors
and that is a good thing yeah uh and so
in in Jesus as well Jesus is a warrior
he is the commander of the Lord's army
is seen in Revelation 19 with a with a
sharp double-edged sword to strike down
the Nations not win a tickle fight you
know and so he put his armor and sword
aside to come to Earth on a hostage
rescue mission right uh but now back in
glory he's wielding double sword again
and when he comes back it isn't to die
and save the world it's to deliver it
and so they don't recognize no Jesus is
a warrior he just gave you a glimpse uh
of uh something different on a very uh
narrow mission to save us an interesting
way to put it kind of a hostage crisis
because I've always said if ever I'm
held hostage I do not want to hear a
woman on that megaphone because it could
just it could get emotionally
[Laughter]
I don't care it's like oh no I'm gonna
die uh but that is you know that goes
back to the idea I know you've talked
about this and you've uh referenced
Jordan Peterson in the past who's been a
long time um friend of mine um the idea
of of bridal strength you know there's
no there's no virtue in being weak and
saying well see I don't use it it's
really easy to say well I don't want to
fight well it's because you can't yeah
right turning the other cheek means you
have a cheek to turn right um and I
think that's a big and I I don't want to
miss her but I think or would you say
that's why you focus on that idea of
sort of masculine um strength combined
with of course humility because it's
something that's maybe been lost a
little bit or the church has been done a
disservice and being overly feminized in
the modern era sometimes yeah I think so
I think the the greatest man was Jesus
who's the perfect picture of bridled
strength right a Dudu can endure the
worst sorry and I just felt immediately
bad calling Jesus a dude uh but anyway
and Jesus abides amen endured absolutely
one of the worst uh tortures known to
man and crucified and yet not not crying
out yeah not crying Gerald would you cry
out I would absolutely cry out I've done
some research into what it means to be
scourged yeah the the lashes and how
they dig into your flesh and tear them
off and then get down into the the body
like basically it's just like having the
back removed off of you to give you and
I would have cried out I would have
cried out too but who maybe I maybe
would have gotten to two the temple
curtain would have been torn when they
gave me vinegar I'm like what the heck
vinegar vinegar and I don't know where
this sponge has been my last drink yeah
my last drink I mean even prisoners get
a last meal I could have even made the
wine just bring me water I would not
have been uh I would not have been very
uh tolerant but you know this brings me
to some I've talked about this in the
past and sometimes Christians disagree
with me on this and I'm curious to hear
your take you used to disagree with me
on this on what
you're about to find out
you talk about Jesus yeah he was he was
crucified and I once had a pastor say
what's the opposite of love and it's one
of those things like a trick question no
matter like well I guess it's hate he
said no no it's fear yeah we fear what
we hate we hate what we fear and I said
hold on a second that implies that fear
is evil you know Jesus lived with he had
to have lived with fear because he would
have had to experience human emotion you
look at him in the garden saying like if
there's any other way and he faced it
anyway it's not being
um not having your actions dictated by
fear now some people have argued with me
and I I could be wrong saying no Jesus
would have never been afraid yeah um
where do you line up on that I would say
I don't think Jesus was ever afraid I
don't think that's a uh necessarily an
emotion that humans have to exhibit so
for instance a terrible there's a
feeling versus exhibiting would be a
behavior I mean he sweat blood which he
was stressed yeah at least stressed that
was before they had the mushroom
adaptogen coffee it was at least I
really would rather not be tortured uh
but I don't know that I would go as far
to say uh fear maybe I should say the
human element of of being re of being
repelled from discomfort but
understanding he would have to go to it
anyway maybe the idea of discomfort
because if he didn't experience
discomfort then none of it means
anything yeah I mean I I believe that
God became a man and he was actually
fully man right uh at that point he was
fully God as well it's the hypothetic
union and so uh that's what I think and
so whatever humans got to do but some
things I don't know a single man who's
never been afraid but I've never known a
single man that could go sinless either
right but I'm saying he has to
experience all that is man just one well
so here I would actually make the
argument that the this The Garden of
Gethsemane experience was not so much
about the physical even though the
physical was a major part of it it was
about the my God my God why have you
forsaken me yeah the time God looks down
and no longer sees his son and having
the first time in all of existence
broken connection
that maybe would be the biggest I guess
if there's a point at which you could
say was Jesus afraid I think it would be
on the cross in that moment where he's
for the first time ever separated from
God but I don't know if I understand
what you're saying about afraid no and I
I you're trying to Define it I agree
with what you're going to yes and I
didn't want I didn't mean to start a
theological debate right off the bat
because I think we agree
but I say because there are a lot of
pastors sometimes who don't do what what
you do and they say you know be not
afraid it's like one second the reason
that we're called to for the same reason
that we're called to you know not after
marital sex for the same reason we're
called it's hard to be Not Afraid in
other words as human beings our instinct
is to be afraid and I think sometimes
that's undersold to Christians like if
you trust in the Lord you won't be
afraid no that's that is the struggle
and that's why we have to trust in God
and I always felt as someone who has
always lived my life very fearfully you
know before grappling tournaments before
live appearances yeah you said you like
public speaking I hate it really I have
horrible stages great at it man I've
always had stage fright every time uh
but I've always felt the need to try and
get past it yeah and sometimes I feel
like investors were missing that I was
like there might be something wrong with
me because I'm I'm often afraid but I
try and get over it right through God
not saying that I'm not saying Jesus was
I'm not saying Jesus was a scaredy cat
yeah that he ran away I can't do it
whatever it came back the very next
three days after we're done I'm gonna
jump in the comments yeah he wasn't
afraid he cats Steve I mean I'm already
all over you all over it well what does
it mean I guess to be a warrior and
you've talked about this and I have a
quote that I find interesting that may
not be historically accurate but the
relevance I think applies you say a
whole man is not part Warrior part poet
he's all Warrior
um and all poet the idea that anything
else is is incomplete first off I think
it's you know how do you balance the two
but I also think this is important
because I do think that you touch on
this and people will misrepresent you
sure they'll try and say this is this
false Christianity machismo which go
watch his stuff you know Warrior poet
you can search it on YouTube they might
not find you go follow them on Twitter
we'll have the links
um the idea of a man being a jock or
being an artist that's a very new it's
almost 80s teen rom-coms it used to be
You Know Abe Lincoln was a wrestler and
he wept I mean Jesus was a powerful man
and he wept with his friends and he
loved you were considered an incomplete
man if you didn't have all these facets
and you talk about all of them but a lot
of times people focus on just Warrior
right yeah I think uh a warrior uh if
you should really love the people that
he's trying to protect otherwise you
spend your time trying to protect uh
those you love and you end up being such
a brute you're insufferable to live with
and you're going to lose the thing that
you protect and I think the poet
understands a little bit better of like
how to actually hey say something that
doesn't you know make your kids hit the
roof and you know you can get along with
the misses and whatnot and so I think
there's different aspects that that
absolutely need to uh be present for us
to be able to just do life well of most
the dudes that I uh know that were in
Special Operations of any kind most most
of them you know are
uh their families fell apart they're
just kind of brutes it's hard to turn it
off it's hard to turn it off and so I
think we need to be able to be strong
tough men and we also need to be able to
be gentle and kind and and romantic and
emotionally available for our kids and I
think that's part of masculinity I was
eating at a restaurant
um recently with my whole family and my
you know my wife and I were talking
about something that made my voice go of
like uh yuck romancy stuff I'm like son
it's half of being a man yeah that's
half of being a man
um that's when you grow up you're gonna
like what it leads to that's right hey
there's some that's in the Bible too hey
Bruce there's some perks to romance yes
she cares a little less about your
deadlift though hey deadlifts are cool
uh she cares a little less about your
deadlift and more about you being nice
right so I think that's uh well I don't
think about you being nice I think she
cares about you respecting her sure yeah
because some people will they'll you
know the comment section right first off
people are going to argue that you don't
have to do deadlifts there you can do
Romanian Devils right now I don't really
care I know but on the nice thing I
think um you know uh it's more about uh
respect and and uh obviously loving your
wife loving your family as Christ loved
the church you know nice I mean Hitler
was nice to some people not out not the
Jews obviously but the point is nice is
something easier to fake than actually
and you know nice can be a flatterer
it'd be very nice for me need to tell
you exactly what you wanted to hear
right but I I think love always speaks
the truth you can't divorce love and
truth in the moment you do love becomes
an absolute fraud and so I may tell you
something that's not nice but it's true
now maybe I'm being kind but not nice
I'm not just saying stuff and I think it
is below a real man to just say the nice
thing but my wife even more than respect
she wants to you know she wants the
sweet stuff you know the pillow talk
stuff as well
loving truth right obviously you don't
want to you can there's a lot of people
in in Christianity in the Christian
world who are right yeah they have truth
on their side right but they don't have
any love right and so and Paul talks to
us about this like it doesn't matter if
you don't have love you're missing the
point on all of these things and so it's
not received and so you can be nice all
day long to somebody but without the
truth
it still doesn't mean anything so I
think people really and it's good I
think I've gone for the other way so I I
would say is we've gone for the other
way where a lot of churches are uh about
because you know they need to pass an
offering plate about nice right you're
incentivized they're feeling not focused
on discomfort right good and we've done
that as a society for example I think
one of the worst hijackings that you've
seen from and conservatives and
Christians will do this and say well I
you know I don't you can identify
however you want to identify if you're
an adult but and then they draw the line
with kids like well hold on a second
you're not drawing the line of truth
because you think people think that
you're not nice I don't think there's
anything unkind in telling someone hold
on a second I understand that you feel a
certain way
um but you're you're not I love you but
you're not a woman and to go out and to
tell other people that they're a woman
that's not nice because they're going to
harm other people and I think that that
truth has to be that dividing line and
sometimes we bend it in the church no
it's 100 so his thing is is Warrior poet
right and I want to know where you got
that and I'll get to that in a second
but it's also love and truth it's not if
you watch the film Warrior and was
reading Robert Frost there you go yeah
exactly I have an idea of where I'm
reading my diary came through how could
you possibly know who is this guy yeah
how can you I'm one of the great cat
burglars of the world your researchers
spectacular I do my homework you have to
have both truth and love it's 100 of
each yeah it's 100 Warrior 100 poet
right like you talked about in your book
but I think I think the the place where
the warrior poet thing are you a Mel
Gibson fan by chance
um I like some of the movies he's making
I like voicemails
well
Justin has made some fantastic movies he
has okay so did you like Braveheart yes
are you familiar with the end of
Braveheart where they fought like
Warrior there you go is that where you
got the name problem oh come on
zero like
yeah
s are completely original no no I ripped
it off bro no that's not even off on the
uh
it's okay I ripped off your diary in
fact I actually thought it was really
cool because I always loved that line
they fought like warrior poets and I was
like well that's great well it's I don't
know what the poet part meant but they
mooned people and then won but Warrior
poet is a freedom fighter it's somebody
who is moved by virtue to risk life and
limb for others and that's what we're
all about now the other part Society
came from Dead Poets Society okay and so
between the two Warrior Poet Society so
Oh Captain My Captain there we go is
Deadpool is that Kevin Klein is that
Robin Williams Robin Williams Robin
Williams and then what's oh Dead
Presidents club right with a it's
totally I just I always get them
confused they're both boarding schools
there's one with Kevin Klein at
supporting school but the point remains
let me ask you this because a lot of
people watching uh right aren't
necessarily military right
um people reading your book you know the
warrior poet way they're not um they're
not necessarily involved in day-to-day
conflict so how would this teaching you
know apply to them the idea of fighting
for what well I mean you don't have to
be in the military to be involved in
conflict conflict has found us there's
no hiding from it it's in your
workplaces is it your own family
reunions which have been divided for
years where you know of like wherever
you fall on covet or whatever you can
you can't even talk to these family
members anymore and sexuality and the
fight is at our doorstep for truth and
we just need men with backbones that
love people enough to actually say I'm
not moving I'm not self-censoring I'm
going to say the truth and if you don't
like it then I am deeply upset by that
because a lot of you you know family but
I'm going to tell the truth right as
Martin Luther would say peace if
possible but the truth at all costs
because the love cannot stand on lies
right and so you know anywhere that
there's a conflict I also carry
concealed every day of my life because
there's a bunch of mental and healthy
people out there that want to shoot
people up and the only way to stop a bad
guy with a gun is a good guy with a gun
so if something goes down when I'm
playing Zone this is my area I'm going
to be ready to defend I'm going to be
ready to protect and so you don't have
to join the military to be able to to be
one of those silent Guardians out there
one of these warrior poets ready to
protect the innocent and so do your part
to stand for truth in your speech in
your workplaces it's gonna Freedom at
this point we're so late in the game
freedom is going to cost everyone
something personally yeah now and so
that's this that's the fight I think
when you're talking about protecting the
innocent right now we are definitely at
a Tipping Point Society where that would
include all children and I don't just
mean the gender reassignment surgeries
and the puberty blockers and those laws
though that is the most severe
manifestation I mean the idea that our
children they have access to a digital
Town Square uh very different from a
public Town Square that may be
completely devoid of truth and that's by
Design and you can't combat that for
example the big Tech censorship with
just being just being nice right truth
has to cut through and that means there
is absolutely a fight I mean there's a
fight in for informational Warfare right
now that is if we're crying out loud our
kids were locked up and they weren't
going to school we have the the highest
depression you know rates that we've
seen in a long time substance abuse
rates and teenagers never seen before we
did this to our kids and that in itself
is a war a figurative War I think so too
one wonderful thing that happened during
the lockdown and it's hard to even say
oh wait something happened that was good
to be yeah a lot of folks found out what
was happening in government schools and
they pulled the plug and they got their
kids back who knows how many generations
will be rescued because of that one
simple thing the homeschooling movement
has exploded now I'm speaking at
homeschooling conferences and dads are
now joining in to help raise these kids
and educate the kids and uh you're
seeing a bit of a ground swelling
movement yeah where Mom and Dad's
working together to actually educate and
to make kids strong ready for a world
breaking at the seams well I've always
thought it was very important and where
I was raised in Canada I knew one kid
ever was homeschooled it was a very
weird thing I don't know exactly what
the laws are but I know in a lot of
other countries and European countries
and in Canada specifically where I was
Quebec they're they're far more
stringent on homeschooling
um and I think maybe yeah with covid we
learned that it's you're more capable of
doing it than ever they were basically
doing homeschooling but with a public
school teacher and a blue you know Chain
Gang haircut oh I hear it and
immediately it just upsets me of like
what do you mean
they're you know allowing you to to
educate your own kids these don't belong
to the gut what what kind of Marxism is
that you're not allowed to teach your
kids what you want you must send them to
the government and the government will
tell them what it is ludicrous to me
yeah that homeschooling wouldn't just be
a complete open door without any
restrictions well that's where they
start from the premise of they're all of
our kids no they're not they're just my
kids they're not yours they are mine
alone yeah yep yeah I'm a big fan of the
homeschooling thing but I think kind of
to Steven's Point they were weird for a
long time no this was just it was a
weird situation oh no they was the only
one kid his name was Simon well it is on
boogers there were a lot of homeschool
kids a long a while back when I was
growing up I graduated in 1998 from high
school I didn't experience any of this
stuff that I remember in school right
none of this stuff that's going on right
now so I understand the move towards it
and I understand like what you're saying
technology had to Spring Forward quite a
bit to make sure that we made it
accessible for people to be able to do
homeschooling yeah right and you know
with zoom and all the stuff that kind of
was there but then really kind of blew
up I it was that people were a little
bit more weird they were not as adjusted
in society they hadn't been socialized
quite as much right now that's going
away with all of the different ways that
people are socialized and it's the kids
that go to school that they maybe run
with their kids for a minute and then
friends but then they come home and
they're on Facebook they're on well
maybe not Facebook anymore the kids are
on something else on Instagram they're
on something they're doing something
else that's not connected to the outside
world right they're just isolating by
themselves we would come home and go
play that's where we got most of the
socialism they didn't experience it
because you were a bully Baby Huey
you're bigger than all the other guys
beat the crap out of everybody I never
beat the crap out of anybody I just was
playing rough and it was early on that's
exactly what it was like exactly thank
you see thank you at least we have a
warrior poet to stand up to you hey how
dare you sir I came to my mind to come
to Jesus moment in third grade when I
accidentally heard a kid who had just
returned from knee surgery and I didn't
know and I ran up behind him and kicked
him and his knee and he's not a boy
disabuse you of your Notions yes no uh
up until third grade no I well yeah you
didn't know he was a nice bully yeah
what what I'm trying to give you the out
to move on he's like I have a nice place
just let it go no it was uh you're now
not a book it was tonight so I was a
nice kid I was bigger and I abused my
biggerness I never beat anybody up or
pinned them against lockers or ran with
a crew that would push down the little
kids that you know couldn't defend
themselves it was just that when it came
to sports I was going to assert myself
and I didn't care if you liked it well
this brings me to another so I I um I
was bullied a lot in school now keep in
mind
you know I was raised in French Canada
um where we don't have conservatives uh
we have liberals and liberal separatists
um and uh there's a very strong
anti-American sentiment an undercurrent
with a lot of sort of liberal Canadians
and my dad always wanted me to be very
proud of being American and kind of
learn where I came from and so I was
very often at odds I mean we literally
would have it was more acceptable to
preach the ideas of socialism which
Quebec is or communism in class then the
idea that hey America isn't such a bad
country now I wasn't uh a physically
strong kid like you so I fought back
with my mouth you know making fun of
whatever it is teasing and then of
course I would inevitably get my my ass
kicked uh but I really wish you know uh
that I had and this goes back to the
idea of bridal strength
I didn't know how to defend myself and I
remember my dad wanted me to learn how
to defend myself as a kid because he
knew that I was bullied and at that
point in time you know I was like it was
karate and Kung Fu and all the stuff
that doesn't work and they make Dojo
stuff and he saw the early UFC he said
there's a sky hoist Gracie I'm going to
send you down to this place they're
teaching Jiu Jitsu at the community
center well was the same guy who taught
me karate and it was aikai jiu jitsudo
and he made me buy Chinese slippers so
he wasn't really teaching Jiu Jitsu yeah
and he actually admonished my brother
and I for wrestling in class he's like
we don't do that get in line oh yeah
um but I think it would have changed I
uh we're gonna celebrate that
punctuation that was really fun so yeah
I had a good Kia uh it comes from it
comes from your diaphragm you gotta he
got to breathe from down here but now
with twins I said I'm not going to force
them into any sport right but they have
to get the blue belt in Jiu Jitsu
because I feel like if I would have had
that tool I would have been able to
de-escalate I wouldn't have been nearly
as fearful if I knew that if push came
to shove that I could have defended
myself and uh it changes who you are and
as a kid being so afraid not knowing
that I could ultimately take care of
that if it came to it definitely forced
me to live in a lot more fear than than
in my later years you know at 18 19.
you know I I I like that idea make our
make our boys strong and able to protect
that's part of why we've been given
strength is to be able to protect right
that's good but the same applies to
concealed carry like you've talked about
the same applies to being capable right
is is having that along it has to come
with a strong moral fiber a backbone
yeah it really does make that's the only
way I think to make good men I think
you're right yeah absolutely and you
talk about it uh so much do you feel
like uh you feel like this is a message
that that isn't heard enough uh a lot
out there and that's why you've kind of
made it your your Arizona diet yeah I
see a lot of encouragement for women to
be strong and bold but you don't really
see the same for men right and uh that
is
unforgivable well I think yeah women
would you say this way often women
um
feminism is lauded culturally right and
traditional masculinity is treated
punitively by mandate and by that I mean
actual like we even talked about Good
Samaritan laws recently no good deed
goes unpunished depending on the state
that you're in where people that's
that's a traditionally masculine trait
I'm not talking about being a bully I'm
talking about protecting the innocent
Zero Tolerance policies in school if a
kid is being bullied if you do anything
at all where I was raised like you could
be getting punched in the face and if
you shoved the bully off you both go
into suspension so there are punitive
damages sometimes levied on on on men
for doing what men have done since the
beginning of time whereas everything
feminine even if it's masculine
femininity is lauded is is is that
something that you feel as a lot of
young men confusing is ultimately worse
for women right and you brought up the
idea of government schools a feminizing
men or young boys as well so it
basically stops that pursuit of being
able to be strong and men need those
kind of Killer Instincts it's going to
help them in every single area of their
life of hey push comes to shove if you
have to physically protect that you're
ready to do that it's also going to give
it'll spill over into confidence I think
you were alluding to this as well so
that you can be strong with your words
and you can be a safe guardian of Truth
knowing that if like oh if this goes to
blow I'm good with that too like in
Goodwill Hunting when he just totally
undoes this dude intellectually and he's
like but then if you want to step
outside
why don't we go ahead and do that how do
you like them apples and I'm like yeah I
was like either one of like except Matt
Damon's five two but the point remains
shut up I mean he's tiny you can fit him
in your backpack
very good he's maybe slightly taller
than Anderson Cooper but no I understand
exactly what you're doing very good uh
men should be strong in every area of
their life and that's socially and
intellectually and mentally and
physically all of it goes into the
strength of a man so if you are it just
absolute jacked muscle head with traps
uh can you guys put traps on me in post
how does this work on the show and we
could with yourself it might look weird
so yeah touche anyway you can have some
just jacked muscle head and then you cut
them off in traffic and he just loses
his mind well this is this is a weak
person that's an unbalanced person yeah
this is your anger is so easily upset by
somebody you don't even know your sports
team loses and you are crestfallen you
can't handle that these your family
hides for a week yeah absolutely give
you time for the next week to maybe get
a win yeah or or you're a week morally
usually when I say weak men I don't mean
oh you're you're your squat is very low
usually I mean no you're morally weak
that means uh when push comes to shove
you'll stab your best buddy in the back
out of fear or to get ahead that's a
weak man most politicians are weak men
and it doesn't mean they're not capable
of damage it doesn't mean they're not
ambitious it doesn't mean they're Cut
Throat it means that they don't have the
moral fortitude the character to be able
to stand for the right thing don't
change what they believe on the polls
they don't believe Jack except more
power more money for me and less for the
people or on ingratiating themselves to
people who they know would do them harm
you know there's this this is kind of
the ultimate lie right you said let's
lie straight from the pit of Hell you
said you would kill me last right with
you'll see a lot of people even I see it
from churches you see it from people on
the right with Facebook it's like okay
we'll play ball with Facebook and not
talk about whatever it is or then we'll
do it with YouTube okay well do it and
then all of a sudden you're on an island
and it's look like the answer from
tyrants is always more right um they'll
never Live and Let Live they'll never
leave you alone why can't they just
leave me alone because that's not what
tyrants do no rule you they will find
you I do think there's hope amidst this
uh sociological fog uh the weakening of
masculinity of people have been pushed
to the brink and then some and people
are waking up and I think cowardice has
spread under our rulers uh for for far
too long and I personally I deeply
miscarriage if I can find a dude that
just has I mean just just show me a
little bit of backbone a little bit of
character and stand your ground and I'm
like I will follow that guy and so it
turns out cowardice does spread but so
does courage and people are waking up
and men are standing up tall with their
shoulders back right well the one thing
that I hope is that you're right we are
seeing that change a little bit right
now but these things tend to over over
correct right you tend to kind of
suppress this so much and there's an
over correction for it it's like that's
I think that's one of the things that
we're fighting against it's like no
return it to its proper place that's
right it doesn't need to go over the top
to kind of counterbalance it just needs
to go back to its proper place and that
that's really my point in the Warrior
poet way is I want to avoid the
historical errors of penduluming back
and forth to these extremes I'm like no
no a warrior can get you through a war
but a poet can live well in peace and
oftentimes military guys good at War
suck at life right you know that you
you're you're good at one of the others
there's some uh it's silly to even cite
but remember uh in one of the Batman
movies I forget which one it was
commissioner Batman come on could be if
you could be going to Batman and Robin
careful try carefully okay Commissioner
Gordon is up on stage he's giving a
speech and they just say like no we got
plans to replace him like well he's at
War here of like yeah but it's peacetime
right yeah okay right and so that's the
Gen general idea the darkness that's an
acceptable one there you go if you were
going to Batman Forever
night it's just all caps it might be
Dark Knight Rises but no that's
absolutely true now I do think there
does need to be some some Grace for for
both sides in other words don't expect a
poet to be a full-blown Warrior and I do
think that sometimes
um having been around these people who
have been in a concussive environment in
war it's like look they can't just shut
it off sometimes we don't do a good job
of bringing them back into the fold and
there's a quote you've heard the quote
jack of all trades master of none right
there's some debate as to the origin I
don't know if this actually comes from
Benjamin Franklin but it was used at one
point that a man should be a jack of all
trades and a master of one meaning you
should be capable in all areas but you
should have an area that you've mastered
an area of expertise and is that sort of
maybe the archetype that you you see
like a warrior poet all these but some
people are more Warrior and some people
are more poet yeah I Trend more lion and
I have to work more on being a lamb uh
you you should be both you should be
Warrior and poet I'm gravitate more
toward Warrior uh and so I have to
through great conscious effort really
cultivate those those poet aspects of it
it's it's going to allow all my
relationships to be intact it's going to
keep my staff from Rage quitting on me
in a year I'm like wow this guy sucks
I'm like uh but too much Warrior not
enough poet right here and so I think
everyone is naturally predisposed to the
other it's just simply it's not okay to
not cultivate the parts that you are
weak at right it's going to wreck your
life no one being part of a team is
probably recognizing and lending your
area of expertise which is like I'm
probably a little more Warrior I'm
probably a little more poet when you're
talking about serving your community
sometimes recognizing your skill set too
right and so for instance the warrior
you know say you're in some debate the
warrior needs to understand how to
season his speech with salt at certain
moments uh to be able to not offend
somebody necessarily of like I'm not
afraid to offend somebody but I
recognize that uh offended brother is
more in yielding than a fortified City
and therefore there is a time to just be
like nope this is truth suck it up
buttercup and there's another time to
say okay this is wrong I can gain more
traction in persuading them if I come at
them like a brother shoulder to shoulder
and that's all I'm really driving at
here is there's a way that a warrior can
become far more poetic in those moments
and it's a good thing and whereas a poet
uh well naturally like oh I don't want
to offend anyone I don't want to say
anything I'm like well then you're
seeding the Battleground to evil which
we've been doing for quite a while and
it's not okay I think maybe a big
difference there as far as when the role
is appropriate is the ability to
identify evil you know I've talked about
this like we do change my Minds where
the vast majority of them are incredibly
civil and productive and then you get
some that aren't yeah because there's a
matching of it there are some people
whose Minds won't be changed and that's
when it occasionally becomes a debate
like there was a girl one time who
showed up and she was very aggressive
it's like well I had an abort it was a
pro-life change of mindset well I had an
abortion and I and she was and uh yeah
and I was everything else that day had
been mostly civil and and this I still
would say but I said and and when did
you have this abortion I said well I'm
going to tell you you're going to meet
that child in heaven one day you're
going to see his eye color and you're
gonna know what his name was wow and um
and she got and P people got really
upset I mean the death threats that I
got she came on the show the next week
and uh she had changed her point of view
on abortion wow which wasn't nice but
again it wasn't about her I didn't feel
that I was looking into the face of
someone evil yeah but I could see this
baggage of evil and from people around
her going like this I have to recognize
the difference here I'm not going to be
able to do it with just the Socratic
method right
um and and sometimes that is I think a
very valuable skill set is recognizing
the minds you can change or people
who've been influenced by Evil versus
those who perpetuate evil on others and
that's where you put your Warrior head
on that's right I think in a public
debate it far more yields itself to like
no Crush these terrible arguments yeah
which are actually doing incredible
damage of like oh no it's minor
attracted person no no no
evil sick twisted pedophilia and if you
engage in a hint of it right let's lock
you up forever and throw away the key
you sick twisted evil individual like
I'm not going to entertain that you're
going to say a warrior in those
coming out she's coming out of like
exactly holy cow it'd be wildly evil for
someone to sit back and let that go as
it can't capitulate to that as if we're
supposed to respect all viewpoints right
cannibalism that's fine I respect your
view I don't respect that Viewpoint
that's a terrible Viewpoint how dare you
what about an air disaster yeah in a
what Fair disaster yeah
they seem that for example for most of
the cannibalism is in the Andes you know
I knew a bully would figure out a way it
wasn't enough we're back to that level
up I want to eat their flesh come up
with a scenario yeah
it's a famous no I think I think that's
important because I think a lot of
people here will agree with it and then
go okay what's the the road and by when
I say roadmap I mean map not minor
attracted persons that's why I also
don't like it we already have the word
Matt means something that's right the
road map like with raising kids you know
parents will be concerned wait how do I
because I because they'll say I want to
make sure that my children both men and
women yeah but particularly with young
men uh because men are more capable of
damage in a lot of ways
um I want them to be strong but how do I
know that I ensure uh that doesn't turn
them into a bully because we've all seen
that happen sometimes too well one great
thing is is I think it's actually quite
easy to pass along as long as you
exhibit that you can teach what you know
but you can only replicate who you are
and if you're a bully no matter what you
teach your kids you're probably going to
make bullies but if you're actually you
know a a strong yet gentle man you
should have both your kids are going to
see that and they're going to naturally
see when Daddy flips the switch right so
the big idea with uh me and my boys is I
think Isis should fear me the Taliban
should fear me but my kids don't right
you know they pull no punches in our
wrestle matches they know they can an
attack Daddy full force and they don't
have to worry about my temper flaring up
or me throwing them through a wall or
something no like I love my boys and
they feel that safety yeah uh and they
know I'm dangerous but they know I'm not
dangerous to them right uh and so I
think if you are those things if you are
a warrior poet you can't help but teach
it you can't screw it up before
obviously you coined the phrase Warrior
put my dad was was that way and I would
say too when I was young he would
probably say that he had you know um
probably didn't have his temper
completely under control uh certainly
never dangerous but he was always so
loved in other words my dad would
discipline us where we feared the
repercussions but he's still one of my
best friends I mean the three people you
met here today like my best friends are
still uh John a Johnny boy he met out
there I've known since I was 12. Gerald
for 15 years and my dad yeah
um and and I can say that one of my
life's greatest blessings but I watched
my dad uh he was always present he was
very very close with my brother and I
awesome um more so than other dads but
then I also saw him get into some some
scuffles or I guess skirmishes never
anything very violent but guys who would
you know um maybe do something
inappropriate with my mom or I'll tell
some stories out because I don't know
what I am allowed to discuss but never
does anything violent or criminal but I
also noticed that my friend's dad's
had a healthy respect of him
um and and uh I always saw that as
something that I wanted to emulate when
I got to an age where kids were like I
told my dad to go screw himself because
I can kick his ass and I was like
I don't have that luxury
um and so he was able to raise me you
know for a longer period of time yeah as
opposed to oh 15 went through a growth
spurt buy do what you want right um and
I'm really grateful um for that I also
want you mentioned wrestling okay again
the book is the warrior poet way tell us
a story you talk about in your book uh
and I think this is indicative of kind
of what we're talking about here Tony
Lopez oh the story in there I don't want
to talk about Tony you got to talk about
the covered everyone's going to love
this because everyone knows a Tony Lopez
was he your bully no he was not no he
was not uh so I was an All-State
wrestler I was I was a good wrestler in
which state uh Georgia okay I was all
caught up in it it was it was like Utah
or Wyoming Iowa or Pennsylvania but
we'll allow it
sorry never mind
wrong state next question what is it New
Mexico that's it all state is but for
people who don't know that's that's very
very high level so so you're good I am
good in other words you walk into most
rooms and you are going to be one of if
not the the top at my school I was the
school's wrestler that's what I was
known for and so I was very good uh Tony
was the girls soccer coach at my high
school
I already don't like the description but
I know how the story ends so I have
Grace for Mr Lopez uh I knew that he was
all martial arts whatever and I kind of
looked down on it a little bit as a
little just uh yeah I'm like I don't
know I was like he he he wasn't like
this specimen figure
just a maybe a tiny on the portly side
or just sort of watch this find me and
beat the crap out of me all over it we
just spoiled the story yeah I'm trying
to do the thing but anyway he had all
kinds of black belts and whatnot but he
showed up at our wrestling practice for
the day middle-aged man nothing nothing
fancy to look at and he was going to be
my my sparring partner and I'm like all
right I'm gonna try not to break this
old man right uh and so we start doing
you know just basic warm-up drills and
whatnot and I'm like man this guy can
really move and he's just chatting being
real nice just chatting while we're
doing this stuff and finally we uh start
actually wrestling and at this point I'm
getting upset because I can tell this
guy just move so smooth and swiftly it
it's not like fighting anybody else on
the wrestling mat of like this guy
there's something different about the
way this guy moves then I'm just I I
held nothing back I went all out and he
doesn't realize that we're in a serious
you know Battle of Olympia he's he has
no idea he just brought you like at the
rage gain in my neck and he he's just
while pleasantly speaking to me you know
while the city that makes it so much
worse yeah and so he's like you're doing
good you're like oh please stop just put
me put me unconscious it'd be more
gracious so I I talk about this uh in
the book of I thought I was the most
dangerous man in the room and I wasn't
uh and so what I learned is part of
being the most dangerous man in the room
is actually humility it was the very
center of uh morality the very center of
Christian morality of pride is the
center of Christian immorality it is the
ultimate anti-god thought Pride then
humility is the ultimate Center of all
morality and that no not me but God and
so uh that for me taught me one of the
most moral uh biggest moral lessons in
my life as well I just happened to
have my ego so well I had a similar
experience except I will say I I
probably the opposite of of you and that
I was bad at everything growing up so I
had horrible self-esteem um I remember
seeing a homeless guy outside of ogles
man I've told the story where I said
that's gonna be me people walked by and
I was like I'm not good I wasn't
artistic I wasn't intelligent
um I wasn't I was a very late bloomer I
couldn't do Sports and everything and I
have no discernible skill set
uh so I always went into everything
scared and I found sort of my Niche
later in life what I was good at you
know no one knew that you could make a
living doing this or I didn't know what
Jiu Jitsu was where I kind of found my
sport later on not a world beater but
was pretty good yeah and um there was a
guy I hope he doesn't mind me saying his
name uh because it was after this that I
found out he was also a Believer his
name is Fabricio Medici so fabricia if
you see this hi thank you he was um and
I trained Jiu Jitsu and Judo in Montreal
but like with an unofficial Club I was
in New York working at Fox News before
and a half years and I hated my life I
just I just because you know you appear
four or five times a week what do you do
with the rest of your time write an
article and I was kind of locked down
exclusively from doing a whole lot else
so my drug became uh training and I did
you just like seven times a week plus
weight training I would do privates
where it's just everything went into it
I turned my joints into a fine powder uh
but this guy Fabricio Medici he uh was
high level I think he won um I think he
might have won like uh uh silver at
Browns you know and he would tell you he
didn't have the the greatest wrestling
so he but he was a really good coach
yeah and small guy maybe 145. and I
didn't think by any means that I was
going to but he said like come give me
more intensity Monty's okay so give me
your instructor and then it was like
walking into a closet full of coat
hangers you know he just like butterfly
hook and grabbing the collar and I just
remember feeling like Pinocchio and
completely helpless
um and then afterwards we were sitting
there and I assumed you know every
Brazilian who I'd known was was Catholic
and you know um I would say very carnal
if you see Carnival very sexual people
uh but he was a really straight laced
guy and I said something in the car he
was driving me back which he didn't have
to do he said well you know we're all
waiting for the same time when he come
back
I said wait what he said what'd you say
did you say I said wait are you are you
saying you're saying who I think you're
saying you mean Jesus I said yeah I was
like I had no idea I don't talk about it
too much with my students and then we
talked and I found out he was a good
Christian guy he was a great instructor
and everyone wanted to train with this
guy even though he was a killer he could
lay you down and put you in a spot where
it's almost more humbling because like
he's doing this easily yeah uh and uh I
learned early on I was very fortunate to
have a really good instructor if I
didn't my gosh my path would have been
different so he was my Tony Lopez it's
funny how common it is for the most
dangerous men alive are humble and
unassuming and extremely nice guys it's
it's you know the lower level guys who
get some measure of skill and it's you
know
um bravado I always want to say vibrato
and that's a yeah that's a difference
oh you know oh they can be cocky sobs
too if they have a perfect you know fals
I don't know it's like just stop laying
it on bullying us with you Josh Groban
strange stuff Les Miserables Eddie
redmain empty chairs every note was
vibrato it was amazing I'm like come on
man spread it around yeah leave some
talent for the rest of us yeah
incredible but uh some of the most
dangerous men on the planet uh and I've
met all kinds of them and all the
different Special Operations that have
worked with uh usually uh very
um humble unassuming dudes that can take
you apart yeah well you have those
humbling experiences right you guys just
described yours and I think that's a
challenge for guys is if they don't have
one of those humbling experiences they
end up thinking that they can kind of do
whatever they want say whatever they
want until they run to that wall
eventually because eventually you will
that's why physical activity like I
think you said we're not talking about
being the most macho guy but it does
matter because it is something
quantifiable tangible in other words you
can't move that weight on that barbell
you can't pin this guy or whatever is
you can't throw that football that
measurable progress for me I don't think
there's a way for young men to develop
self-esteem any other way outside of
becoming excellent at something I think
suffering produces character and there's
no short cut yeah you want to be a good
man well then you've got to be you've
got to suffer right and there's just
suffering produces character and
perseverance endurance and so that
there's no shortcut
yeah but what would you say let me ask
you this because there are a lot of
people and I agree with a lot of what
he's like for example Andrew Tate talks
about math and I think he's writing a
lot of what he says as far as you know
young men are hurting and they need to
be told not to be hyperly emotional but
to be disciplined in regulating their
emotion there are things that he says
that are right and then there are things
that he does that kind of do as I say
not as I do
but um people say it's a men's rights
thing and we've been doing this on the
show since what Cassie J back in 20 I
don't know 15 16. young men who are
hurting their suffering but they feel as
though they're suffering with no end in
sight right no kind of redemption that's
what a lot of young men feel where
they're brow beaten for being men and
then they're not as good at being women
and they're just checking out of the
dating pool 40 something percent of
young men don't want to get married and
60 something percent of young women say
there aren't men worth marrying
do you see that as a reason that maybe
sometimes people like the Andrew Tates
the world that's why young men tend to
gravitate toward them and get maybe a
piece of the puzzle but miss another
component yeah so um I haven't followed
Tate for long I tried and then I said
something he didn't like and he blocked
me on Twitter yeah and so uh anyway he
he mentioned somewhere though that uh
Hey to talk with me if you give fifty
thousand dollars to a charity of your
choice then I'll tell you like I will
take him up on that uh so I would love
to talk with Andrew Tate on masculinity
in a forum like this now I'll I'll
donate the 50 Grand to a charity of my
choice yeah that's okay and I'll I'll
show it all up and I would love to talk
to him uh I think you'd probably agree
on more than you disagree and then and
then that last stretch but that last
stretch is is really pernicious it's a
really big deal right because he is uh
yeah we agree on some big pieces of hey
self-accountability and be strong and
and and tell the truth and I love all
that stuff that he puts out but if Chris
or I mean if humility is the center of
morality you know for me and and I think
that it is and and that's part of being
you know you can't hold together deep
relationships over long periods of time
without a measure of humility you become
unsufferable and he's leading folks to
be consummately arrogant and prideful no
one's accusing him of being humble yeah
uh and I think that is really really bad
it's he's serving up a beautiful steak
mashed potato beautiful meal with a
little arsenic in there and it's deadly
and so I do not want young men emulating
all of Tate there's some pieces there
but you could go other places and get
the full thing as well I like some of
the things he says but holy smokes that
is a dangerous path and it's going to
destroy your relationships or destroy
the things that matter the most to you
and you'll end up with flash cars maybe
in a lot of money and you're going to
die alone and miserable that's what I
think right because that was going to be
my next question some young people are
in a stage where they think
Fame flashy cars they think those are
things that I want it's Fool's Gold it's
Fool's Gold uh whatever celebrity that
you can achieve whatever riches are
filled with untold amounts of poverty uh
there's something so much about Andrew
Tate will never know the depth uh that
I've experienced in my joy with my my 16
year bride my kids he'll never get a
taste of that he doesn't have the
relational character and the humility to
be able to pull it off he'll never know
what he's missing or maybe he doesn't
have it now
I always tell people we never and I'm
not just talking about but in general
with young people like I say look you
don't know how the story ends how many
times have you been in the worst spot
and then it completely changes I mean
how many times have you known people
who've been diagnosed you know with
terminally ill and it doesn't happen how
many and it does happen sometimes but
the truth is you don't know how the
story ends so you have to behave and and
exercise in your day a day treat it as
though it can turn around and you'll
still be around for that yeah uh and and
I think yeah that's those are kind of
when you're you can't really live that
way if you're looking at Riches of the
now right yeah um and maybe he'll have
that humbling experience but the problem
is that I think some of it is also you
know he has a Persona which has been you
know which is something that he needs to
needs to do like there are people out
there sometimes where it's you know
Muhammad Ali was friends with a lot of
the guys we would Trash Talk
um part of it is the entertainment side
of it so you don't know how much of it
is for sure disagreement versus you know
kind of a path too yeah I mean when you
look at kind of how Andrew lives his
life and the things that he has and kind
of what he espouses like if if there is
that moment where there's a humbling
experience it's going to cost him a lot
more because he's gone so far in the
direction of what would appear not to be
a humble existence or a humble life
right right and so the fall has to be
greater necessarily so at those heights
yeah and uh Tate gets to live however he
wants I'm like I I don't need I don't
feel the impulse to adjust him or fix
him it's all the Young men that are
looking for emulation and I'm like guys
I get you see some of the strengths in
what he's saying but what you don't
realize is there's a bridge out ahead
right and if you follow him you're going
to drive over it he is tempting you with
fool's gold right but I think it would
be dangerous and yes he's doing some
really good stuff out there too so I
don't want to take away from no no I
agree with you and I think a big part of
it is it highlights the uh to me it
reflects the disservice of the church
that has done to a lot of young men
because a lot of young men are not
taught they're taught to suppress Matt
they're masculine Tendencies period
um I mean people think most pastors are
men but if you look at Board of Elders
and influence in the church and the way
that they conduct a lot of even Sunday
school it's not designed we we often
complain about public school if you look
at the way that often churches will do
Sunday school or daycare it's still
designed for young girls and I know that
a lot of young men who are Christians
feel in a pragmatic level they'll say
yeah but
okay I get half of this message and then
I'm constantly wrong for the way that I
am
um and so they look out there and say
hey look this these relationships are
broken the the male female Dynamic is
broken and it has not been fixed for a
lot of young people sometimes I get
feedback in the church they often leave
the young Christian Singles group
feeling more hopeless than they went in
um and so they they gravitate towards
they're it's not just I use them as an
example he's the most sort of notable
example
um but there are a lot of people out
there who who discuss this right now a
lot of young men are are suffering with
feeling like there's no end in sight
right and I hope they can help find
obvious some answers all the answers
earn not to not to spare your book but
you know the Bible that book but this
book and how big
so the warrior post said it's not a
Christian Movement it's actually a
secular one right yeah everybody's
welcome I happen to be a Christian I've
got some biographical stuff in there as
well so you're gonna hear from me and
I'm gonna say my thing but a lot of
folks in our society they're not
Christian some are atheists or agnostic
stick or Hindu Buddhist or you know all
kinds of new age which is you know most
everybody uh so it's like I don't like
the title I'm like that's so new age to
you to even say uh so uh but I'll
definitely plug Bible in the book uh it
is such a shame that there's a
disconnect uh in what some Churches
teach and then what really gritty first
century Christianity looked like these
were these these men led the greatest
Revolution uh that the world has ever
seen literally Jesus had split time into
2023 years ago with his birth and so
it's like holy cow and they couldn't be
bullied they knew truth they loved
people they served them they lived off
the land and they're getting scourged
and beat with rods and stoned and thrown
out of like do you know the type of
character and strength that you've got
to have to do that this this stuff
really happened and this was
incredibly strong men in every area they
were bright they were uh you know gritty
and tough and so it is a shame that we
so poorly emulate uh that today now I
also say as a caveat uh that it is true
it's easy to find the churches with weak
feet pastors it's unforgivable uh well I
mean forgivable but you know of like
it's a terrible terrible thing they're
not exactly accusing Jesus of being the
Demonic fit but you know but it's just
crappy it's really really bad but I'll
also say some of the greatest strongest
men I know occupy pulpits and are
vibrant members of the church and it may
not be that the church is broke it's
just you got to find the right one and
there may be this amazing family of
Faith it's the healthiest brightest most
creative strongest people I know are
Christians living and breathing in the
church yeah but it's it's all the time
well the Christians a lot of times in
churches want it to be perfect
yeah in practice practice it's messy
like you said these are gritty tough
people that are out there in the first
century Church taking this message to
the masses it wasn't perfect right it
was a very messy situation I think
today's church I I unfortunately a lot
they have a blind spot and what I mean
by that is
um
and I understand it but we have people
who will watch our show we have a lot of
pastors we'll watch the show and go like
you know I'm telling I don't tell people
in the congregation but I didn't watch
your show I go great you have a Netflix
membership
you have to hide that from them because
we occasionally have you know we have
people by the way on the show who like
who aren't necessarily Christians in the
show so you know I always say it's a
PG-13 plus but I'll also have Christians
and Jill knows this who will reach out
and say
that was the first time I had any idea
the books that were in my kids school
and I go you mean the porn and I'm
saying this even right now you mean the
one where the there's a picture of the
kid jerking off in the picture because
your pastor says there's evil in the
world show the picture of the that your
kids are seeing of a young boy
masturbating there can be this
disconnect of uh Netflix and we kind of
have this one portion of the world and
then we can only speak Christian this is
the first time with a lot of people who
say we are flawed we are Christians but
look this is the world that you are
living in yeah and I always tell people
this is not a show meant for kids it's
meant for adults right so they can
protect and I always say this protect
and inform their children but that is a
disservice if people are in the church
and they're shocked at what we show them
that their kids are already reading yep
and I don't know that today's church is
is there are some and that's what I want
to speak they're in the unwell it's yes
but even then it's like there's General
evil and then there's this specific
prescription for good yeah but people
aren't really faced with the evil that's
not condoning of it but like people need
to know the books their kids are reading
and people need to know the directions
that are taking place in the library so
they go well they go and they see it on
Twitter but it never makes its way into
a sermon where I think it's are the kids
gone at Sunday school this is today's
Sodom and Gomorrah that might read a few
more warrior poets I think I think I
think you're right we canceled Netflix
the moment cuties Swiss really myself
too gone forever now uh cancel Disney I
don't know it's like like a grab bag of
like eight things yeah it's Disney Hulu
and ESPN Hulu we had uh it was like a
free whatever thing deal we we had uh
and it was the commercials that came on
yeah that were so outrageous my nope
gone free nope too expensive for us for
this service and so we've just been uh
you know uh relaxing I'm boycotting so
many companies as well put my money
where my mouth is something that was
really upsetting to me uh we moved so we
live way out in the country uh without
postal delivery and trash pickup we live
out in the sticks uh but does Amazon
Prime deliver
um sometimes okay sometimes depends and
I was like well where is this I was
waiting on drone delivery what's the
heat index Amazon can barely pull this
off but we were going to a church Roe v
Wade was uh overturned and then a few
days later Sunday and the Pastor said
nothing really nothing said zero would
you leave yeah we left yeah yeah we left
I've had an experience like that and I
say it's because by the way there's a
pastor who I love a guy named Pastor uh
Jerry
old man older man sorry Pastor Jay but
you are older older than what bald you
know sorry Pastor Jay but you are bald
would seem to mure
um and I always say actually I gave him
this lever action rifle because it was
the only thing he could hit the
broadside of a barn with because he
loved going to the range with me and he
you know loved watching the old The
Rifleman
but this is a guy who in his church a
small area northern northern Michigan
with 40 people
he didn't care the the overarching sort
of it wasn't denomination with the
umbrella of his church too I don't want
to name it they were saying well you
maybe don't want to talk about these
things he said I don't care I'm going
that to me again doesn't I don't know
what the guy can deadlift probably
nothing
that's a man yeah that's a man who's not
afraid to lead by example it's great and
I would never feel the need to walk out
of his church even if he's remaining
silent I know it's because he's he's
he's picking his spots that's right um
but I've never left and and that's why I
think sometimes people get this
misconstrued because you know you're a
fit guy you're a young guy we're having
a cigar but the truth is we're talking
about men who serve their communities
leave their communities and care about
them and are willing to protect them
yeah and I think it's an important
message and I hope there are more guys
that we're going to go to uh to to mug
Club here in a little bit uh I wanted to
ask you before we go and by the way the
book is it's the warrior poet way or the
warrior poet's way poet way okay and
where where can they get the book
everywhere books are sold but if you go
to the warrior poetway.com uh that
that's the landing page for okay does
that mean it's in this still in the like
three remaining Barnes and Nobles
most bookstores have very few books it's
all like Games and Harry Potter craft
and yes you know if like it's just like
I can't find any of the books I've I
like here it's just they'll have a few
Classics but it's kind of like the
well-known Classics and nothing else Fox
and talks and then there's these weird
uh there's these weird categories I
don't even know about uh yeah like you
know Japanese comic book things that
would be oh and a massive section yeah
and then like philosophy it's like
nothing like lgbtq AIP children's books
and you're like you guys got Steinbeck
uh anything no War and Peace all right I
guess it's just the comic book for me
um in your uh is it pistol three class
uh that you that you uh teacher take
part in yeah so we teach pistol rifle
classes around the country okay because
I was reading your book I'm trying to
remember the pistol three I know three
gun is different and you talk about an
exercise that you do
which uh at first glance could seem a
little weird so I'd like for you to
explain it to people because it was
interesting to me um well explain what
it is where you have people basically
church so we want people to be better
protectors uh and you're carrying guns
the only way to get good at gun fighting
is to gunfight that's it so you learn
draw stroke fundamentals you do all that
jazz you learn how to shoot and stuff
that's kind of like hitting a heavy bag
but at some point you got to put on
spats or you got to put on pads and Spar
so you make them shoot each other we
make them shoot each other and not
deadly places with training Munitions
see the bully again I was ready for this
I shoot them and then do something
you're like all right don't move until
bang oh and he would put a dummy around
in their gun and he's yeah exactly well
you ever seen the crow yeah
oh yeah this went dark Steven Seagal
predicted it was time to protect it I've
seen you soon parts of the crow I don't
remember it very well it's okay anyway
in pistol three uh when people are just
being introduced into force on Force
engagement their heart rate's up because
these these little Munitions I mean like
it's got It's like getting hit by a wasp
you know it is not a fun thing so their
heart rates are up and what I do is I
want to teach not just the fighting and
mechanics and the tactics I want to do
some stress inoculation training which
means the big thing is you got to be
able to master that fear I want you calm
as a cucumber when the world is falling
apart right and so what I'll do is I'll
take two dudes I'll put you face to face
you'll reach out hands so that you're
both touching fingertips and I'll just
hold y'all right there you're just
holding fingertip to fingertip and I
just let them wait there for a while
partially because it's good to let them
sit in that horrible moment of
anticipation and yeah try to master fear
and make a plan and another part because
I'm a terrible human being and I think
it's really fun that's the warrior lest
the poet yeah I said I follow Jesus and
saying I was anything like him trying to
process pistol three may change one day
I wouldn't hold your breath this is what
I do it works wonderfully and then on my
command of fight do whatever you think
is best uh and so dudes will go for it
disarm which we've taught them or
they'll break contact to shoot or
they'll just draw and go for no Rex
quandoisms here figure it out and you
see really quickly all the things you
thought would work well in your in your
keyboard Commando way right and then
you're like that didn't work at all I'm
like yes I know right I told you but I
had a 45 in here 380. it didn't there
before nope that's not it it is not the
size of the bullet it is the placement
of the round for sure so we would all
agree 22 not the ideal defense rounds
obviously nope not a good though it is
the most lethal caliber I believe in
America well it's because it's very
common well yeah ubiquitous but it's
also terrible in that a 22 will enter
your body and ping pong around and oh no
don't do that it'll it'll tumble but it
won't bounce we did we just did it with
actually with guns and gear where we
went through he was like it'll tumble
but it doesn't bounce around right but
just some folks will get hit here and it
comes out here and no one wants to be
shot with anything it it yeah it's awful
and so they're treating this and then
you have a massive internal hemorrhage
that they didn't know about and it was
enclosed and so anyway people die from
22s yes exactly yeah nine millimeter is
really the caliber that won right yeah
that would make sense that's the one
everyone's carrying nine yeah and
there's there there are different
choices but it's one of those things
that's like look if it's something
that's adequate and you can fire it
effectively it's people get really off
on the mind and often I find people who
get really off in the minutia these are
people who aren't really interested in
the macro improvements that are
necessary like you're talking about it's
like I I if it doesn't start with a four
then you might as well just be carrying
a fly swatter it's like great maybe you
should lose 200 pounds at 420. and uh
yeah it happens all the time right it's
about being a jack of all trades and at
least a master of one being both a
warrior and a poet we're going to go to
uh to Mud Club uh wherever books are
sold and you can follow of course John
on Twitter Instagram if you're watching
right now on Rumble right this is July I
know it's often dead for news but hit uh
hit the like button you can click this
button below and you can continue to
watch on my club or maybe we'll just
talk about uh I don't know we'll talk
about uh fighting stuff and evidence oh
you have an idea yeah does it involve
you hitting somebody guys well I don't
like where it's going it's going to
involve someone else being hurt not him
the bully that's fair click the button
Rumble thank you YouTube you can urinate
that way